A powerful category of connector are arbitrators.
These are primarily responsible for facilitation services, but
because they can redirect control there's also a coordination service they
provide. You might be able to use them to negotiate service levels.
That is how much resources are being devoted to a particular problem.
Hence they support reliability and atomicity, scheduling and
load balancing, trapping of faults and even synchronization.
Some of the variations for arbitrator connectors include how they handle faults.
Typically with a simple arbitrator scheme, there's a single decision made but
more complex systems might involve a voting scheme. That is if there are three
arbitrators around, they would have to vote on the course of action and
the majority would rule. How concurrency is dealt with. The mechanism is it
semi fours, a rendezvous, monitors, locks there's lots of approaches to this.
And whether it's a light weight approach or a heavy weight approach.
Variations involved with transactions such as whether they're simple or
they're nested. Whether the arbitrator is there if you need it or is required.
And whether the arbitrator supports reads, writes, or both. And
then a major category of, of capabilities and variation of arbitrators involves
security. Authentication, authorization, screening, durability that
is how long the particular decision last. Is it a single session, or
is it a multi session? And then the scheduling of the arbitrator activities.